this video is brought to you by Aura hi
welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
it's no secret that the world is plagued
by scammers most of us are
inconvenienced by their attempts weekly
we receive emails text and calls from
people pretending to be someone that
they're not
from false bank account alerts to a
message saying that a package that we
didn't order has been delayed scams come
in many forms some are simple but others
can be highly complex while falling
victim to a scam can lead to severe
financial hardship for individuals The
Fallout from complex schemes can cause
widespread destruction such was the case
for the people of Albania 26 years ago
in the late 1990s Albania experienced
one of the most devastating Financial
crises in modern history and it was
caused by pyramid schemes that promised
a high rate of return Investments
two-thirds of the entire country
invested But ultimately the schemes
collapsed as they always do and the
result was catastrophic the life savings
of many albanians was gone and this
spiraled into an angry population a
Civil War and then the death of
thousands it's a wild and sad story in
this episode we'll take a look at how
This Disaster happened and the lessons
that can be learned from this tragedy
this is the story of how pyramid schemes
destroyed Albania
you are watching cold fusion TV
before we jump into this wild story let
me tell you about today's sponsor aura
your information is accessible to
scammers robocallers and telemarketers
because of data Brokers these companies
will sell your information for a profit
Aura is here to help Aura identifies
data Brokers that are exposing your
information and automatically submit
opt-out requests on your behalf they'll
even opt you out of junk mail and
telemarketing lists Aura also monitors
your email addresses and passwords to
see if they've been involved in the data
breach and exposed on the dark web they
also give you recommendations on what to
do next not only this but aura's app
also features a VPN password manager
real-time credit and identity theft
monitoring internet parental controls
and malware protection it's basically
almost every Internet safety tool you'll
ever need all inside one app and it's a
lot cheaper than getting these tools
individually let Aura do the hard work
for you and keep you safe online if you
sign up now Aura will give you a
two-week free trial with my link
aura.com coldfusion if it's easier you
can scan the QR barcode it'll also be
the first link in the description thank
you
to understand how a pyramid scheme could
collapse Nation it's best to start by
understanding how they generally work
I've done a full episode on this but
essentially pyramid schemes are a legal
investment operations that promise
higher returns but are designed to cause
significant financial loss for those who
fall victim to them a small group or
individual offers a product or service
which they claim can generate higher
Returns on investment in reality the
product or service is often substandard
or doesn't even exist at all they rely
on recruiting new investors to pay
earlier investors forming a pyramid
shape at first it works the new
investors get paid but not from the
returns of the service but from the
money paid by new members although as
the scheme grows it becomes
exponentially harder to pay everyone
back eventually the scheme collapses and
this leaves the lower tier investors
with significant financial losses and no
hope of recovering their Investments but
meanwhile those who invested early and
managed to sell in time stand to make a
large profit
sadly these schemes are all too common
and people fall victim to them daily
sometimes they lose a little sometimes
they lose their homes and life savings
but on this occasion a whole entire
nation lost everything
[Music]
in the wake of World War II Albania fell
under the control of dictator envir
hallel hoxa and this sparked four
Decades of Communism in the nation the
Albania he ruled was one of widespread
poverty and ruin scarred by the wounds
of War
and hoxha an authoritarian leader set to
rebuild the country by any means
necessary
in the early stages of his rule his
government outlawed traveling abroad
private property ownership and the
practicing of religion
clerics landowners and peasants who
resisted his rule were imprisoned exiled
or even executed but despite his
authoritarian ways the country did
improve in some aspects
increased infrastructure investment led
to improved transport and facilities and
the country slowly recovered and began
experiencing economic growth increased
industrialization and urbanization but
even as economic factors slowly improved
over the following decades the heavy
authoritarian hand of hoxha continued to
be felt that was until 1985 when finally
the long-raigning dictator died
by the late 1980s people had begun
speaking out many citizens particularly
students had become highly politically
active and started to push back against
the communist anti-religious state that
had ruled over them thankfully for the
people of Albania the successor to hoxa
Ramis Alia was a much more Gentle Leader
and following widespread protest
campaigning and eventually a
full-fledged revolution in 1989 Albania
was on the path to electing a political
party chosen by the people and in 1992
Albania's Democratic party was in power
following Decades of Communist
dictatorship Albania began to transition
into a capitalist country
it was a gradual process
the new government began to implement
economic reforms including privatizing
state-owned Enterprises and liberalizing
trade these reforms were designed to
attract foreign investment and promote
economic growth this did lead to the
emergence of a small fledgling private
sector but the transition wasn't easy
Albania had been isolated from the rest
of the world for many years
infrastructure and external investment
wasn't there so it had a weak economy
and the government struggled to deal
with corruption and the emergence of
organized crime but something much more
devastating was coming
[Music]
under Democratic capitalism Albania was
really struggling to find its footing it
was the poorest nation in Europe and
after Decades of being under the boot of
dictatorship its citizens were
Desperately Seeking to climb up the
socio-economic ladder at the time
Albania didn't have many Banking and
investment opportunities and because of
this there was little Financial
regulation to be found and this would
play a huge part in the disaster and
moreover these people were very poor
uneducated and desperate and most
importantly they had little to no
experience with capitalist market and
this all left the people of Albania
sitting ducks for predatory investment
pyramid schemes and the pyramid schemes
did arrive that were operated by various
companies many of which were not
registered with the government and were
owned and operated illegally
the mafia predatory foreign investors
and those who held influential positions
under the Communist system all saw the
opportunity to take advantage the
investment proposals from these
companies promised extremely high
returns some up to 50 percent per month
of course if you're financially
illiterate this is ridiculous but to the
people of Albania it was an opportunity
of a lifetime the people of Albania had
an experienced capitalism before so they
probably just thought this is the way
that people in capitalist Nations invest
and get rich
while all of this was going on the
government not only turned a blind eye
but openly and actively supported these
pyramid schemes and this only served to
increase their appeal government-backed
with a 50 return per month sign me up
the schemes quickly gained popularity
and many albanians invested their life
savings 25 firms held the majority of
Albania's creditors of those 25
vefa was the largest firm they had 60
000 investors and all of these investors
believed that their money would grow at
rates far exceeding what the banks could
offer the thing was vefa was actually a
legitimate company they had a chain of
supermarkets and petrol stations and
their brand was on everyday Goods so
they were somewhat of a trusted brand
the Ponzi scheme however claimed to
invest in Industries such as hotels
stores and factories but of course the
returns that they promised were
completely fake
the internet hadn't quite arrived in
Albania yet so it's not like he could
just go online and really research the
company you're investing in
the people of Albania sold their assets
their homes their land all to claim a
stake in what they understood to be a
safe bet a life-changing bet
and by 1996 two-thirds of the entire
population had invested an estimated 1.2
billion dollars in these schemes and
this was 10 of the nation's GDP
you have to know that the average
monthly income of the nation was eighty
dollars per month
sadly it would not be long before they
discovered that their Investments were
unsustainable and relied on a constant
stream of new investors to pay returns
to existing investors by late 1996 the
schemes had reached their natural
breaking points
v e f a the PowerHouse of the industry
collapsed and this triggered a wave of
panic among investors it set off a chain
reaction amongst all the major firms as
people panicked to withdraw their money
the other firms collapsed too many
albanians lost everything and they were
understandably angry and then a period
of social unrest began
with large amounts of material
possession sold to invest everything and
having lost it all and having no way to
get their money back the country was
thrown into chaos
the collapse of the pyramid schemes had
devastating consequences for Albania the
country's economy was severely damaged
the citizens wanted compensation or even
Revenge everyone from Farmers to police
officers and soldiers had been ripped
off and there was widespread poverty
even worse than before
social unrest riots and protests
occurred across the country thousands
took to the streets in every populated
Center Across the Nation hunger strikes
took place at universities initially the
protests against the government were
peaceful everyone simply wanted their
money back but in February of 1997
government forces responded by firing on
the demonstrators
this was the spark that ignited a Civil
War and the beginning of an uprising
prime minister Alexander Mexi resigned
on the 1st of March 1997 and president
Sally barisha declared a state of
emergency the next day a week later the
Socialist Party of Albania appointed a
new prime minister but it did little to
appease the People by then the
government had lost control of the
situation
the police and National Guards fled
leaving their armories wide open for
looting militias and criminal gangs took
the weapons and the armories were
emptied seven hundred thousand guns were
looted and the population was only 3.5
million
for months crackles of gunfire could be
heard as citizens were putting their new
guns to use treasury buildings were
robbed and destroyed armed gangs were
formed and was every man for himself
this chaos led to a full-scale rebellion
and a month-long Civil War
two thousand albanians sadly lost their
lives in this fighting
news of the situation began to spread
around the globe on March 28th the
United Nations security Council sent
seven thousand troops to Albania this
was to restore order and oversee relief
efforts in mid-april surrounding Nations
launched a peacekeeping force to assist
and by Late July peace had been restored
the United Nations and other
organizations continue to provide
humanitarian Aid and a new government
was formed through elections held in
1998. the new government faced many
challenges there were still widespread
corruption and now they had a completely
ruined economy worse than it had been
before but in time eventually
painstakingly order and stability was
restored to the country and it laid the
foundation for Democratic reforms in the
following years
the Albanian Revolution was a defining
moment in the country's history and the
country would struggle with political
and economic challenges for years to
come
the Ponzi schemes that took down the
country of Albania in 1997 had
far-reaching implications the population
has actually been falling as Citizens
left for Greece Italy Germany the UK and
the us as the publication the
conversation points out there's been
many empty ghost towns left in the wake
of the disaster
but interestingly since 2020 there's
been a slight migration wave there may
be hope for the country as it makes
drives in developing its infrastructure
and improving its business sector
although of course it still faces
corruption and organized crime
challenges Albania has made significant
political progress though in 2009 the
country became a candidate for
membership into the EU
and to meet the requirements of the EU
they've had to do a lot of work and this
has been good for the future of the
nation
but when all is said and done the
collapse of its economy and the
resulting Civil War is a stark reminder
of how vulnerable we can all become when
desperate and faced with the promise of
a more prosperous future
it's also an important reminder to pay
extra attention to any investment
opportunity that you're involved with
so there you have it that's the wild
story of how Ponzi schemes destroyed an
entire nation and caused a civil war
so thanks for watching if you want more
fraud videos I've got plenty of those
otherwise there's other stuff on
business in general or even Science and
Technology it's all here on Cold Fusion
alright that's enough for me my name is
Togo and you've been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
it's me thinking